live from the lobby of the headquarters
of Ramsey solutions tim is with us hey
Tim how are ya pretty good how are you
God so you've been to the counselor or
the coaching training all week with
Chris Hogan yes I just got done with it
did you learn anything I love I learned
so much it's just packed in my head I
love it
well congratulations we appreciate you
coming through and congratulations on
your graduation from that so you have a
question for me actually Dave I have a
question for somebody else great so I
love you I love you more than anything
you laugh with me you teach me and you
support me and you love me you make me
the happiest man in the world
so with that Rachel
I love
the ring goes on the finger is it paid
for the finger I don't think we heard
you say yes real loud say yes relax
congratulations how far the Valentine's
engagement yes not many people get
engaged in front of 10 million people
probably the worst like I hate being in
front of people he's been planning this
for quite a while he's been in touch
with our staff our team has been working
on it he knew he was coming to the
coaching training and so uh yeah you
this is this has been talked about a
while Rachel so congratulations you guys
thank you so tell us your story how long
have you been dating since earlier last
year uh-huh
we met through a friend of a friend
mm-hmm and really kicked it off got to
know each other and just kept on meeting
each other and and she was actually the
one that that told me about you Oh I had
previous education where I learned about
leveraging debt and the whole different
side of of Finance and I was used to
that she told me about you and I said
this guy's crazy paying off the house
you know that's you know that's good day
that's what I was nothing so she taught
me about you and we got on your
principles and I've been get free I mean
for like two and a half years way before
him
that's fabulous
uh well we've only done on air
engagements a couple of times on this
show and you guys just did one of the
best ones ever so we're very very proud
for you guys congratulations thank you
happy Valentine's Day Tim and Rachel
newly-engaged from Sacramento California
happened right here in our lobby and if
you are watching on the HD channel you
got to see it happen and if not you can
go back and watch it again it'll loop
through and I'd say we'll probably post
that as a YouTube what do you guys think
I'd say that'll show up as a clip so
very fun I mean I don't know who was
more excited Tim or everybody around
here the the whole team we had to beat
the team to keep all 500 of them from
coming out to watch this happen because
word got out this was gonna go on we
won't blow his surprise but yeah he was
nervous and everybody around here was
excited so it was great
folks that just happened that is the
lovely ring that Tim gave Rachel at his
Rachel's beautiful hand and beautiful
ring here comes Dave to congratulate Tim
and Rachel on the proposal how about
that incredible things on fire well done
dude and Dave it's hard enough to
propose to a woman it's nerve-wracking
enough to do that by yourself in the
woods and in front of you 8 million
listeners I mean I thought he did a
great job he did a good job he's like
he's you know he's an old pro or
something nah wait wait wait wait wait
maybe not well yeah and they're FPU
coordinators and that that kind of rock
is pretty nervous he really wants I ran
into him I hear earlier don't sign his
book and I was trying to play it off
like I didn't know who he was and oh
that's Rachel yeah and he's just like
deer in the headlights he didn't blink
for two minutes before you went live
with him great job and this is a special
moment there FPU coordinators by the way
about that FPU allows you to get a rock
like that there you go yeah but more
importantly a woman like that fact well
said
dave ramsey matchmaker right here ladies
and gentlemen thanks Dave all right so
now here you are like as soon as you
finish the proposal okay and we kind of
went to commercial break I came up to
you and you look like you were about
ready to faint I mean come on dude how
does it feel to be through that moment
and now this woman has said yes to you
it's crazy when you're thinking about it
the time time just slows down enormous
ly and you're trying to think of the
words that you would plan to say am i
saying them too fast or am i saying I'm
too slow or are people looking at me you
know we were all of us were looking at
you we were all rooting for you pal it's
just crazy and then and then when when
you get on the knee and she just says
yes it's it's all over here's a little
backstory I mean honestly I interviewed
Rachel I think it was in the first hour
I have walked through the lobby as you
all know sometimes and I just talked to
people and I didn't know how much she
hates like being in front of people are
on camera but she was literally mad at
me
right before the proposal she had no
idea what we're gonna do but how are you
feeling now Rachel I'm feeling good cool
so you guys teach how many classes have
you taught is just one only only one so
far and I was just the assistant the
first time this will be my official job
exciting now Tim who's watching from
back home of course we are on the HD
video channel who's watching from your
side a lot of people from adventure city
of Yuba City and still nervous Rachel
and so a pastor back watching my folks
back did you talk to that her mom and
dad what was that did you do the
old-fashioned what you do there that's a
little interesting so let me give that
you haven't talked to her parents they
well he lives in Nebraska and we live in
California we'll give you a pass so this
is gonna be a big story you're gonna
share today right my gosh the video will
hop out the video is phenomenal you guys
have that in HD forever and ever
all right now this is this is so fun I
have to ask it's been 10 minutes have
you thought about a date yet I would be
lying if I said no are you thinking I
gotta hear this I love that in ten
minutes you've already started planning
this is such a woman bride thing to do
what are you thinking I'm hoping for
like the fall I like I really like the
fall weddings you know let me give you
some advice from a guy who's been
married almost 17 years at this point
you do nothing else except that's fine
that's fine
because you guys are all in agreement on
the budget right yeah that's gonna be
fun are you starting off the marriage
debt-free oh yes how huge is that all
right here's what we want to do our
friends at Family Life longtime partners
we love them so they teamed up with us
to do something special for you guys so
Laura our producer is bringing this in
here she comes
we've got some beautiful flowers and
Laura will hold those but let you see
those flowers so there you go happy
Valentine's Day from family life and
also we have got a little suitcase which
basically signifies that our friends at
family life are going to send you guys
to
one of their 70 locations you get to
choose for a weekend to remember it's a
fantastic weekend where you can just get
away and be together and work on that
new marriage and it's gonna be a lot of
fun so you get to pick that and weekend
to remember calm is the location for
those of you who would like to get away
and work on your marriage whether it be
your communication you just need some
time alone it's relaxing and it will
equip and encourage your marriage we
have a special for you at weekend to
remember calm use the code Dave and you
save a hundred dollars on what will be a
weekend that you'll never forget and
it'll help your marriage so hey on
behalf of family life and the Dave
Ramsey show congratulations thanks for
sharing your story with us we're so
thrilled folks what a great show the
good news more show is coming up right
now